covering one
square mile of new york city brooklyn's
greenwood cemetery is a national
historic landmark
more than 500 000 people are interred
here including the inventor
samuel morse composer leonard bernstein
artist jean-michel basquiat and rapper
pop smoke
it's also the final resting place for an
untold number of american war veterans
now the cemetery is enlisting an army of
volunteers to help tell the stories of
those
who served throughout our nation's
history
greenwood cemetery's sprawling grounds
over 476
acres in brooklyn new york has been
called a green
oasis a place that serves as solace and
peace for some
historical record for others from its
skyline views of manhattan
to its landmark chapel jeff richmond is
the cemetery's historian it's a constant
treasure hunt here i don't think a week
goes by
where i don't find out about somebody
fascinating
who's interred here at the cemetery
richmond isn't just talking about the
rich and famous
in 2002 he made it his mission to
identify the cemetery's
military veterans starting with the
civil war
at the time did you know how many civil
war
soldiers veterans were buried here i had
no idea
we did have one volunteer and he had
been walking the grounds for 20 years
and he had a list of 250
and so i was young and foolish back then
and thought that if he had 250 perhaps
we would find another 250 and we have
well past 5 000 and it goes beyond just
the name on the headstone
with each veteran tied to an online
biography
after the civil war identifications the
greenwood project turned to world war
one
how did you go about finding out more
about these people well fortunately with
the internet now
with a number of websites there's just
extraordinary information
out there it might be an obituary from
1903
saying here's this person's story and he
served
in and so those are kind of the magic
words
served in the 51st new york infantry and
then we can go from there
the liberation of every town like this
one strasbourg capital of alsace
lorraine
requires staggering supplies of
ammunition world war ii
is greenwood cemetery's current focus
these are people who were there at
normandy
and they landed who fought their way
across the pacific
also we have come across a rosie the
riveter
who uh went to work and so just this
loving description from her daughter
about my mother would dress up for the
factory where she was working
and so she would wear this kind of
industrial outfit but
the daughter was very careful to point
out that
after work she would get back into her
dress
as a lady and come home to her family
family sharing stories and even
documenting them
my grandfather was in the army and my
grandmother was in the navy as a nurse
um and they met while in the army and in
the navy serving
and that's you know history is made
catherine amore is one of about 20
volunteers currently compiling stories
and pictures of the cemetery's world war
ii veterans
including her grandparents sebastian and
susan amore
her grandfather served as a corporal in
the army's seventh armored division
which saw heavy combat in europe from
1944
until the end of the war her grandmother
served in a women's naval reserve unit
known
as the waves waves learned combat
tactics
okay miss third class yeoman we know
when we're licked
they met in louisiana where the seventh
was training and were married
for 41 years after the war i'm learning
more about how much history is out there
of them
whether it's pictures whether it's just
stories that are documented in
newspapers
yeah because i know their lives i knew
what they did but not necessarily those
pieces of history
learning about another generation often
teaches us something have you learned
something from this the greatest
generation
that's a good way to put it right um i
think what i've realized is that every
generation has their struggles and every
generation
has their times that they look back on
and whether they regret it or not
you know saying this is what i can learn
from i can learn from this
and if we don't document it right how do
we learn from it
volunteer barbara buchholz has been
working on the greenwood veterans
project from its inception
she is also the daughter of a world war
ii veteran
as you've learned about some of the
people buried here
it's also made you curious about your
own
father as a veteran my father his uncles
they never talked about
world war ii and we never asked about it
even when we were older and then
unfortunately when our parents passed we
find the pictures
my dad was in normandy he was in belgium
he was in
the european theater italy and
it's a new part of my father that i
didn't know about i'm learning about my
father
and i didn't give much thought to world
war ii
until recently for you what stood out
in learning these individual stories
just how important it is
us for us to remember them and tell
their story and to focus on
just what makes life worth living
volunteer jessica waverka doesn't have a
familial tie to any of greenwood's
veterans
i want to know what motivates them what
motivates them to come from a small
midwestern town to new york they joined
world war
ii what inspired them to enlist but
you'd never know it when hearing her
talk
about those she's researched like
private frederick budgel
he was 17 years old when he's enlisted a
few months shy of 18.
he went down there on a thursday on a
tuesday he was sworn in
went off to world war ii came back he
had nine children
he was an iron worker proud iron worker
for 45 years
we were with her when she visited
private budgel's gravesite for the first
time
what does it mean to you to see the
headstone this is no longer a stranger
this is someone
i have to think you feel like you know
it makes me proud to be part of his
story
and to part of telling his story it's a
pride greenwood's other volunteers and
jeff richmond share
by sharing the stories of those who
sacrificed
to serve our country why for you
is this so important ultimately a
cemetery is about
remembrance and so these monuments and
these memorials
that are out there remember the people
but there are stories
behind each of these lives
and so we're trying to share those
stories and collect
those stories and it's just been a
wonderful opportunity and it's stories
that help us
learn history learn from history there
was one volunteer barbara who we spoke
with
and she knew her dad was in world war ii
but she never asked any questions and
unfortunately he's gone but now she's
started
looking into that and wondering about it
so nice to see the mom
take her kids there so they can learn
about history and learn about why people
made that choice
to serve yeah i think about it it just
makes
your relatives those people who came
before us
real like they were here they made
contributions
and they're in many ways like us yeah we
don't think of them that way though but
that
that is exactly it it's that remembrance
and they are still looking
for more veterans that are at greenwood
cemetery if you have information
on a world war ii veteran who is buried
at greenwood you can fill out an
information form online at
greendashwood.com
and yes they do expect maybe to turn
this into projects for also like the
korean war and other wars that came past